كان التصويت النهائي في كلا المجلسين
ساحقًا من قبل الحزبين أكثر بكثير مما
شعر أي شخص بأنه ممكن،
لذا أود أن أشكر أعضاء
الكونجرس الذين صوتوا لتمرير هذه
الاتفاقية التي سأوقعها
غدًا وأصبح القانون الذي
يمرر اتفاقية الميزانية هذه أمرًا
بالغ الأهمية.
لم يكن من الممكن أن يكون هذا أعلى من ذلك لو
فشلنا في التوصل إلى اتفاق بشأن الميزانية، فقد
كانت هناك أصوات متطرفة تهدد
بأخذ أمريكا لأول مرة في
تاريخنا الممتد 247 عامًا إلى التخلف عن
سداد ديوننا الوطنية.
كانت أكثر كارثية،
أعلم أن التوافق بين الحزبين صعب
والوحدة صعبة،
لكن لا يمكننا أبدًا التوقف عن المحاولة
لأنني تقريبًا مثل هذا
الذي واجهناه للتو كان
الاقتصاد الأمريكي والاقتصاد العالمي معرضين
لخطر الانهيار، ولا توجد طريقة أخرى بغض
النظر  ما مدى صعوبة سياستنا، نحن
بحاجة إلى أن نرى بعضنا البعض، ليس كأعداء،
بل كمواطنين أمريكيين
يعاملون بعضهم البعض بكرامة واحترام.